i
a
[Música]
ah
río de janeiro vuelve a abrir las playas
pero solo de lunes a viernes
los fines de semana sigue siendo
prohibido acudir a playas como esta en
copacabana precisamente para evitar las
aglomeraciones hay que destacar que los
últimos días los cariocas se estaban
soltando un poco estas medidas de
cuarentena se vean a cada vez más
personas en la arena también hay que
decir que la playa en río no es
solamente ocio representa el sustento de
centenares de ambulantes que venden
alimentos y objetos en la playa y con
eso consiguen ganar el pan de cada día
sigue prohibido permanecer en la calle
por la noche es decir de 23 horas a las
5 de la mañana también las fiestas y los
espectáculos están prohibidos mientras
tanto los expertos recuerdan que quizás
no era el mejor momento para una
reapertura brasil camina hacia los
400.000 muertos abril fue el mes más
mortífero desde el inicio de la pandemia
y ya sabemos que los primeros cuatro
meses del año murieron por covite más
personas que en todo 2020
[Música]
en chile y tras más de un mes de
confinamiento absoluto a partir de este
jueves 10 comunas de la región
metropolitana y de santiago entre ellas
está la que nos encontramos volverán a
la fase 2 es decir a un desconocimiento
que permite a las personas volver a la
vida normal de lunes a viernes y
mantener las cuarentenas sólo los fines
de semana esta decisión ha sido tomada
con la alegría por parte de los alcaldes
de estas comunas o barrios sin embargo
ha sido también muy criticada por el
colegio médico que afirman que no están
dados los criterios epidemiológicos para
iniciar el descongelamiento en chile-
cuando los hospitales todavía registran
una tasa de ocupación del 95 por ciento
muy preocupante y se registró una cifra
récord de personas ingresadas en las
unidades de cuidados intensivos esta
nueva fase permitirá a las comunas tanto
reiniciar las clases presenciales para
los alumnos en aquellos colegios que así
lo deseen como también volver a abrir
los moldes
aunque eso sí con un aforo reducido el
gobierno también anunció que se
mantendrá el cierre de fronteras durante
un mes más
[Música]
en uruguay el presidente luis lacalle
pou informó que no piensa tomar más
medidas contra el kobe 19 pese al
incremento exponencial de fallecidos el
primer mandatario lo recibir la segunda
dosis de la vacuna de laboratorio
sinovac reiteró que él no cree en la
cuarentena obligatoria ha vuelto que
queda nocturno como medidas para paliar
la situación dijo que la situación se
revierte con más vacunación cuidados
personales y una atención médica pronta
el grupo asesor científicos recomendó al
gobierno uruguayo tomar más medidas que
restrinjan la movilidad ya que el país
se enfrenta a una segunda ola de
contagio desde el mes de noviembre y no
han podido parar los mismos
[Música]